à droite bien du tir à l'arc l aveugle
avec une distance de 5 m mélanie chambre
un travail ses automatismes
objectif de cet exercice avoir
l'exécution parfaite en insistant sur
les détails de couche bien la cuite ira
bien que les omoplates et qu'ici ce soit
bien en contact et que ça dégage bien
derrière
j'enlève un un sens qu'elle a vu dans le
but de pouvoir vraiment se concentrer
sur chaque élément de son corps après
plus de 20 ans d'équitation mélanie a
commencé le tir à l'arc
il y a près de deux ans est fausse j'ai
cherché un sport que je pouvais
pratiquer j'avais un petit peu et c'est
une tir à l'arc mais sans plus il ya
quelques années auparavant ça m'avait
bien plu j'ai un petit peu regardé je me
suis mis à un club pas loin je vais
m'inscrire et ça m'a plu fréquence de
l'entraînement quatre à cinq fois par
semaine avec son coach cyril au
programme techniques de tir répétition
du geste notamment sur la distance
olympique à 70 m et toujours le souci de
la précision
c'est une sacrée compétitrice et qui on
veut qu'ils en redemandent même quand ça
marche elle devra vous dire non ça
marche pas c'est pas assez bien c'est et
ça on peut pas lui en vouloir
cette persévérance a permis à mélanie de
décrocher le titre de championne
départementale de tir à 50 m et la
médaille d'argent de tir à 70 m
aujourd'hui elle travaille
d'arrache-pied pour le championnat de
france prévu les 25 et 26 juillet
prochains
donc il faut que quand on lève l'arc
l'oeil tankini si vous avez un point
rouge le point rouge doit les landes
jaune et ensuite on lâche pourquoi
est-ce qu'on choisit le titre à la fin
martin à mes élèves je leur dis
finalement leurs études c'est comme du
sport je sais bien qu'on français on
bien d'accord les exercices de grammaire
et de conjugaison personne n'a envie de
les faire mais il faut il faut passer
par là et c'est tout mais séance à 5 m
c'est comme lors les exercices alors je
parle du français c'est valable dans
toutes les matières quand mélanie
n'empêche pas ses flèches elle fait
découvrir son autre passion aux plus
jeunes l'écriture écrivain et professeur
de français dans un collège
elle intervient aussi dans des écoles
primaires durant les temps d'activités
périscolaires
elle accompagne ses élèves dans la
création d'un mur ils ont chacun leur
histoire avec leurs illustrations
vraiment qu'ils sont voilà pour mettre
en valeur leurs textes et ils sont
acteurs de az de leur propre livre
on commence avec une feuille un stylo
une idée et là ils vont vraiment écrire
c'est à dire qu'ils vont trouver leur
idée moi je vais les aider à construire
leur pensée à hiérarchiser leurs
histoires pour que pour créer du sens
j'écris pour les enfants mais ça
m'intéresse est de partager avec eux à
la fois des histoires la passion et leur
donner l'opportunité de le faire
eux-mêmes
depuis quatre ans elle a écrit dix
livres pour enfants trois livres sur
l'équitation
d'autres sont des premières lectures ou
encore une enquête se déroulant à royan
son prochain récit pourrait être
intitulée sina princesse rebelle
on a une jeune fille tina qui se
retrouve en 3ème année dans un dans un
pensionnat puisque c'est le passage
obligé pour devenir uniquement pour
scénariser au prince et aux princesses
sauf que elle elle aimerait bien être
ailleurs la sortie de cet ouvrage est
prévue pour septembre 2018 avec comme
cible des 9-12 ordre